sur le terrain les combats sont toujours
aussi intense et les pertes immenses
chaque jour une centaine de soldats
Ukrainiens D7 soit environ plus de 60
plus de 10000 selon le début de la
guerre indiqué un conseiller du
président zellenski l'état-major
ukrainien a précisé hier que les forces
ukrainiennes menaient des Asos sur la
ville de Severo donies mais sans succès
les soldats Ukrainiens qui ont remboursé
l'armée russe ce week-end près de roue
briveka ou encore près de mikolaïve vous
savez cette ville portuaire qui se
trouve juste à côté du port d'Odessa ils
ont réussi également à reprendre des
localités comme Travis que dans la
région de rerson tout ça a été annoncé
hier soir par le président zellenski et
puis comme vous le savez également
depuis plusieurs jours les
multiplications les appels se
multiplient pour demander à des armes
aux Occidentaux puisque les Ukrainiens
ne cessent de le répéter il manque
réellement de munitions et d'armes
lourdes de longues